my name is Michael Braun and I teach at
Rainier Beach High School in Seattle
Washington I teach a mobile computer
science with Chris Mitchell and peli de
lieu of Microsoft they work with the
teals program our students were addicted
to their phones they constantly have
their phone out and so we brought this
class we brought mobile computer science
class to the to the classroom and we
transform what the students were where
we were having a problem with their
their addiction to their phones into
something that they are using every day
and it's their only source of their
hardware and software I think this class
really helped explain how a lot of
Technology a lot of what we see today is
made like when I'm playing video games
for example I wonder how they could make
something look like so real you know and
this explain a lot this class explained
to me a lot on how that works I learned
like about scripts applications um how
all that is made usefully I liked
working with the turtle that was fun I I
really got that a lot so yeah a lot of
it was just repeating like telling it
how long I want the line to how long I
wanted to draw the line and then
basically repeating it and telling it
which angles I wanted to turn it and
just like repeating that the kids
absolutely love the program we come from
school with set over seventy percent
free reduced lunch and about ninety
percent minority population and half of
our classes girls in the first time
first trial of this class
we've had extremely successful results
and our students are being being more
than consumers of up technology they are
creators of technology
you